J'écoute l'équipe cet équipage parle de
famille mais le jeu a changé maintenant
Dominic Toretto est devenu un voyou tu
vas tourner le dos à la famille
Je sais qu'il semble que ne les abandonne pas
les pouliches nous n'avons qu'une chance
de  rendre cette famille entière à nouveau je
veux que cela soit fait vraiment une chose je peux
garantir que personne n'est prêt pour cela
elle est une définition même du terrorisme de haute technologie
il y a des milliers de voitures dans
la ville et maintenant elles sont toutes à moi maintenant je
sais ce que ça fait  comme être chaque flic
jamais pris attends attends Oh
Londyn Abu Dhabi Cuba notre peut-être de
croix avant l'aube peut Justin le savoir Je
pense que je dois te rappeler pourquoi tu as choisi
d'être ici Je n'ai pas le choix si tu
vas  attrapez Dom, il aura besoin d'un peu d'
aide si vous voulez me dire pourquoi vous venez de
me mettre dans une pièce avec ce thé et des
crumpets étant des criminels notant que la
citation est une sorte de plan de repas de circulation
, vous devriez avoir de plus grands soupirs
vous allez travailler  ensemble
je l'ai attendu nous  j'ai un tank
maintenant Oh bébé
haha
abandonnent pas ta journée il pensa
t que ça allait être un comba
de rue comme une roue quel méchant fou h
ha d'accord tu obtiens des point
de style pour celui-là je ne
sais pas  pourquoi tu fais ça mais je
sais une chose tu m'aimes feu
[Musique]